welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series i am your host greg
knuckles and i'm joined today by my
co-host eric drexler eric how are you
doing i'm doing great how are you
uh you know what honestly not doing my
best today just uh just putting it out
there for the listeners but it is what
it is and uh you know gonna gonna
soldier through anyways
well we appreciate it
uh
so
as i mentioned on on the last episode uh
it was somewhat up in the air about
whether this would be the last fireside
chat before
um
you know more sciencey and content heavy
episodes came out or whether this would
be the first sciency content heavy
episode back
um
anyway
it's it's going to be one more fireside
chat normal episodes will resume as
normal next week uh but for today just
just some more uh
light-hearted off-topic content and uh i
hope you enjoy it um
just as a bit of a show note
something to potentially put on your
calendar
is that on september 16th we are going
to be recording a live bonus episode of
the podcast um
so it's going to be sort of like the the
macro factor launch party that we did a
year ago it's going to be to celebrate
the anniversary um we're going to be
primarily wanting to address macro
factor related questions if you use the
app
but if you're there in chat and you're
asking about other stuff we will
definitely make a point of uh getting to
questions about other topics as well so
uh put that on on your calendar
september 16th we're thinking for now it
will probably be
around 8pm eastern um so
the the best place to get notified about
that is if you're listening to this on a
podcasting app in particular uh go to
the stronger by science youtube channel
uh subscribe ring the bell etc
so you can get notifications for when
that's scheduled and when it goes live
sounds good cool
all right yeah let's uh let's hop into
it uh with questions
so from the facebook group
andrea farmer uh asks what are some
things that seem difficult to cook or
bake
but is actually pretty easy and worth
trying
so as the
as the cook uh here here on the stronger
by science fireside chats i i figure i
figure you should i figure you should
lead it off okay cool yeah at first i
was getting a little defensive there uh
yeah as our resident chef uh i want to
answer this a little bit differently um
obviously anything that requires any
skill or effort
to cook it's really not within my
realm of expertise i focus on doing
stuff that is extremely easy easy to do
and
you know
i've talked about my perspectives on
food before
i don't go for like really
uh elaborate meals or very good tasting
meals i try to get right in the middle
like on that state that scale of hedonic
enjoyment from one to ten in the middle
of
not difficult to make and also not
tasting good just kind of like the the
venn diagram of those two things now
what i try to do is make it a 10 out of
10 in terms of easiness and then for
flavor like maybe a 4 out of 10.
if i can get into that sweet spot i'm
happy
um
now if the easiness level starts to
drift down
to nine or god forbid as low as
something like eight then i'm completely
out i'm not gonna do it so i wanna
answer a slightly different question i'm
sure you'll have a good answer to the
actual question but
um i want to talk about
vegan and vegetarian
meal options because
one of the things i noticed like i guess
uh since i've mentioned it
uh
on the show and i talk about it a little
bit in the facebook communities and
stuff like that
i've seen a lot of conversation about
vegan and vegetarian diets and some
people who are like you know i've
thought about you know making the switch
or i've thought about maybe you know for
part of the week having days where i
don't eat any meat products but like as
we all know it's almost impossible you
have to be an excellent cook and it's
prohibitively expensive uh and those
things to me just don't really
seem accurate um and like i'm not out
here trying to convert anyone to any
particular way of eating but like i i
noticed that when i switched to a
vegetarian diet
my meal preparation did not get any more
difficult at all um it actually got a
tiny bit easier if that's even possible
uh and my my cost per meal actually went
down so
uh i wanted to share a really really
easy dinner that i make that is
like
super easy super cheap and keeps me
happy so
i've been eating this a lot lately but
what i do is i just get frozen
vegetables spread them on a baking sheet
i put aluminum foil on the sheet so that
i don't have to wash it after
put those in at like 350 get some edible
which is what you're going for
get the rice cooker going with white
rice and
they'll finish about 30 minutes later
pop open a can of garbanzo beans also
known as chickpeas uh mix it all
together put on some teriyaki sauce some
soy sauce and it's great and the way i
got to this meal was i basically
started with like an elaborate tofu
based stir fry and i just started
eliminating all the things that were
even remotely challenging or labor
intensive and all of a sudden you know
you end up with a meal like this and
you're like hey it's great and it's uh
you know relatively low energy density
you can increase the energy density just
by just you know increasing the amount
of rice that you're throwing in there um
yeah easy to make vegetarian super cheap
and uh minimal cleanup which is huge
another thing we've talked a little bit
about uh in mass and i think we've
mentioned on the podcast uh food texture
and how that can influence uh rate of
eating satiety things of that nature i
actually i like i said i used to make
this with tofu and then i got too lazy
to cube the tofu which is just
it's like five minutes for god's sakes i
don't who has the time so i said i'm
just gonna open a can of beans and put
it in
when i switch from tofu to the chickpeas
i noticed that the satiety that i was
experiencing in the meal actually did
appreciably increase and i think the
texture has
part of it's probably flavor part of its
texture
but you can you can kind of mix and
match that kind of main protein
ingredient
and find that perfect level of satiety
that you're looking for sweet sounds
good yeah what do you got yeah so i i
have a few um one i mentioned on the
podcast before and that is risotto for
whatever reason people think risotto is
very fancy and hard to make
uh it's not it's just rice that you
just stir instead of leave alone
that causes it to release more of the
starch that's what kind of thickens the
whole dish up and then i mean beyond
that it's it's rice with just like some
some form of like flavoring in it
generally there will be uh just like
some aromatics that you cook beforehand
that you stir into the rice and then uh
before it's quite done you just finish
it with some butter and cheese easiest
thing in the world it's just rice that
that you stir the whole time
um
i i think a lot of people are
intimidated by making bread just in
general
[Music]
either they think that the dough is
going to be very sticky and hard to
handle or they're
concerned that
you know they're they're not going to
time everything 100 perfectly and like
their bread may be slightly overproofed
or under proofed
and the thing is
it is i think somewhat difficult to get
really really good at making bread
but the thing about bread is that
homemade bread is always going to taste
good
so
you can there is a very wide latitude
for being able to screw it up while
you're learning how to make it and still
have a
very delicious product at the end and
it's also something that you can ease
into if if any of these things
intimidate you so especially if if
you're
concerned about like being able to
handle the dough well if it's going to
be too sticky
the thing about dough is that the the
stickiness is pretty proportional to how
wet it is so
just start with with drier doughs to
begin with and that's not going to give
you
like super airy bread with like large
bubbles like a like a rustic hearth loaf
or whatever but that's fine like you you
can start with something easier and then
as you just get more and more
comfortable handing handling dough you
can work up to higher and higher
hydration dose
so it's it's something that
if you did just jump straight into the
deep end it might be pretty challenging
but it's something where
you can start with with very easy breads
and then just work to more and more
challenging breads over time so you know
there is kind of that progression and
entry-level breads are are quite easy to
make
um
something else that i think intimidates
people is making uh caramel or caramel
at home however you pronounce it uh
and i think the thing that concerns
folks the most is that as they're trying
to caramelize their sugar that it's
going to
crystallize on them and isn't going to
make a nice smooth caramel uh there are
two things
three things you can do to help with
that
so ultimately
um
ultimately like sugar starting to
crystallize has a lot to do with how
much agitation occurs and just if
there are
intact sugar granules because like it's
it's a crystal it's like a crystalline
structure sugar is and the way crystals
work is basically if there is a seed
crystal like further crystals can just
kind of propagate from there um so
that's that's what you're concerned
about uh and so
and
generally like there might be like a
couple sugar crystals somewhere in your
pan
but like i said agitation matters a lot
too so if you're just constantly like
mixing or agitating the mixture a lot
that's just going to put more molecules
in contact with each other so if if
there is that crystal in there
things spread quicker so there are a few
things you can do to make caramel very
easy and nearly foolproof
one is uh just to add extra water to get
it going so
you know instead of like i think a lot
of
caramel recipes i've seen online say
like i'll start with like a cup of sugar
and maybe like a tablespoon of water
just to get everything going you can
totally do that but if you're not in a
rush you could add like a quarter cup of
water a half cup of water
and basically make simple syrup to begin
with and then just boil it down from
there it will take longer because before
the sugar will start caramelizing you
need to drive most of that water off but
if you're not in a rush that's totally
fine uh also if you're not in a rush
which if you're not experienced making
caramel you shouldn't be like you should
take your time and and
uh in you know do it well instead of
trying to do it quickly uh but just turn
the heat down uh like to low or medium
low like basically the lowest heat that
will boil water instead of trying to
keep the heat really high
so one that's going to give you a longer
timing window for when you stop the like
when you can stop the caramel without
burning it um but it's also just going
to agitate the mixture less because you
don't have as intense of bubbling so
like if a crystal
uh like
if crystallization starts
it won't spread as much or as quickly uh
and then the last one and like this is
this is basically a hack like i i don't
know how long it took me to learn this
little tip
but once i learned it i was like oh
never mind i wish i would have known
this the whole time makes it almost fool
proof
whatever whatever pot you use try to use
a relatively
like skinny pot so if if there's one
that's like skinny and tall
uh that's fine if you don't have like a
specific pot for caramel making which i
don't uh you can just use a normal pot
but you know if you're gonna be going
with like a cup of sugar don't use like
a 12-inch frying pan or something like
that you want you want the smallest
amount of
uh like circumference of the thing
you're making uh
the thing you're using as possible like
that
reduces
kind of the surface area along the sides
for crystals to start forming and then
here's the here's like kind of the hack
just leave the lid on so
like
that does a couple things for you
until most of the water gets driven off
it's going to keep the humidity up
inside the pot i said a couple things
does one thing for you but it's very
important thing it keeps the humidity up
inside of the pot and if a crystal like
if crystallization is going to start in
your caramel it's generally because
like you got your sugar mixer you got
your sugar mixture going it's boiling
it's simmering along whatever
some of it splashes onto the walls of
the pan and then
all of the water is driven off of this
very sugary water droplet that went on
the side of the pan and now you have a
little sugar crystal and if other sugar
comes in contact with it it'll start
crystallizing not good so just by
leaving the lid on like
water will still evaporate out like
there will be enough steam pressure in
inside the pot that the water will get
driven off but it keeps the humidity
high enough within the pot itself
that those uh
those droplets that splatter onto the
side of the pot won't completely dry out
and crystallize like it'll just
flow back down into the rest of the
mixture
much more easily
um so yeah just add a little extra water
to start with keep the heat low and
until
most of the water is gone and the sugar
starts changing color just leave the lid
on the pot um
and that
that's like 90 percent of it and it
makes it
so much easier uh and like i said not
completely foolproof but nearly
foolproof
and then the last one like this this
does stretch the definition of pretty
easy but worth trying so the this last
one does still take some effort but i i
put it on here because i think people
find it unnecessarily intimidating and
that is croissants uh which
now i'm not even gonna try to to
pronounce it the proper french way i get
i get made fun of every time i try to do
that uh but anyway
croissants
like it is
pretty time and labor intensive uh but
i think people get
i think people get intimidated by it
because
they're concerned like oh like what if
what if i accidentally rip the dough or
what if the lamination doesn't go
perfectly
or you know what if i don't leave the
dough in the fridge quite long enough
and the butter stays a little bit too
soft and some of it gets worked into the
dough what if i leave it in the fridge
too hard between folds and the butter
gets too hard and it's hard to roll out
uh
so
all of those things will happen if
you've never made croissants before and
the good thing is
it doesn't matter uh if you're
if you're an amateur baker
no one is expecting your croissants to
come out looking
like the perfect croissants that they
might get it at a professional bakery
like they're
they're simply not expecting that level
of aesthetic perfection
and
uh in terms of just generally how the
product will turn out like will it will
it poof correctly will it have the right
texture
it will uh
it pretty much always will unless you
just really really screw something up so
if you start with like half melted
butter like yeah things are probably
gonna go awry um
but like i've i've accidentally like
ripped the dough when i was making
croissants before like i'd turn it over
like as i was rolling in and be like oh
no there's butter smeared on my
countertop like
it's leaking out it's not gonna get a
good puff it's totally fine um
i've got the butter too hard before and
like the sheet of butter itself cracked
as i was attempting to roll it out and i
was like oh no it's going to be uneven
whatever still totally fine thing is
when you put
that much butter in dough
you're not ever going to work all of it
into the dough there's still going to be
enough layers that you get that puff and
that crunch and that texture that you
expect from croissants
is going to taste like dough and butter
which is
one delicious into exactly what
croissants taste like
um
and so essentially like it is is
labor-intensive and and quite difficult
to make perfect croissants
but
you can
screw croissants up to a
nearly infinite degree
and
like when you put them in the oven
you're like oh no this is terrible this
is a disaster and then just magically
they come out of the oven and they're
great
so
you know it's it is very hard to get
perfectly but it's also incredibly hard
to screw up to like an unredeemable
degree so if if uh puff pastry in
general or laminated doughs intimidate
you uh they shouldn't like you you will
screw them up uh anticipate that but
even when you screw them up it's still
gonna turn out tasting good looking good
um and and generally being a delicious
confection
you know we're very different people
greg when i think of a starch i don't
say what kind of
special type of bread or dough can i
make today i'm like
how long does my rice cooker take
that's the only question rice cookers
though without without rice cookers um
which were very affordable by the way i
think my rice cooker was like 12 or
something nice i think i'd be dead i i
don't think i would be able to feed
myself without it i i mean to be clear
like all of the things i just listed are
things that i
i never and i don't think have ever made
for myself yeah
it's just cooking for other people yeah
for
for myself for starch purposes i do
also like almost exclusively eat rice
it's very easy and delicious yeah i
think i've had all of these things that
you mentioned um
and all of the ones i remember have been
fantastic so
all right well thanks man
yeah so moving on we've talked about
some good dishes how about some terrible
dishes
yeah i'll i'll start with this um
so for me i i've made a lot of truly
abominable ramen um like like instant
ramen
and uh this was all
when i was very young so i i think i was
always interested in cooking but
um
yeah
my
i like i don't want to say like my
parents never cooked for me or or
anything like that uh but there wasn't
that much kind of like
direct tutelage from my parents to me
about how they didn't throw you the
apron and say come on
stand next to the stove i mean they they
did from time to time but it was mostly
like for desserts like if yeah you know
if we were making like a box cake mix or
something um you know my mom would have
my brother and i come into the kitchen
and be like oh we need two eggs can you
grab two eggs like oh we need to mix
this for five minutes can you use the
mixer or whatever um but you know
she wouldn't say like ooh we're going to
uh you know do do a reverse sear on some
steak so like here's how you check the
temperature of the pan like here's how
long you cookies like there wasn't too
much of that yeah um
but i i did always think cooking was was
interesting and i wanted to be good at
it
and we always had a lot of instant ramen
on hand in part because it's just
delicious and in part because it's very
cheap um back in the day it was like 10
cents per package right yeah yeah uh the
the marachon the top ramen you could
sometimes get 20 for a dollar whoa
i i mean i i don't know like that's
awesome you grew up in the big city uh
but out out in the country where i lived
you you could get
when it went on sale you could get ramen
for five cents a pack it was it was nice
um so when i was trying to learn how
just like flavors and seasonings worked
uh so this was like early high school
like 15 16. um what i would do for
breakfast every morning is i would just
make uh like a pot of instant ramen not
use the flavor the flavoring packet uh
and just try to season it myself to you
know just try to figure out what
everything tasted like how everything
worked and
i would say 40 of them were just
absolutely abominable uh
basically inedible but but i ate them
anyway um
and really the the main thing i learned
from that whole process is just
the appropriate amount of salt to use in
things
uh because really i mean that's
that's where things really go awry like
you can you can save most dishes
unless you either get them just way too
some strong flavor so if something is
tremendously too spicy like the the
saying uh the solution to pollution is
dilution like
that's true but it's also finite you
know if you put uh five times as much
salt as you should in a pot of ramen you
can dilute that with five times as much
water but like now it's not really ramen
anymore it's like a thermos
of salt water with like some noodles
floating around in it uh same thing if
something's like way way too spicy like
yeah you can dilute it but
again you're basically
you're you might be going from making a
soup to just making water with some
stuff floating around in it um
but yeah i mean as far as most at least
like savory foods go
um if you don't
massively under salt it or you don't
massively over salt it
or you don't add like way too much of
any one particular flavor so i i love
garlic uh but i i've i made a lot of
ramen where i added way too much garlic
powder uh to the point where even i was
like damn that's too much garlic um so
unless you find yourself in a situation
like that where you just had way way too
much of something but particularly salt
um
you can generally save it and salvage
something that's pretty decent so yeah
the i think the main lesson i learned
there was just how to solve things
appropriately but
until i learned that lesson i made i
made some just dog [ __ ] ramen yeah and i
should mention we're responding to a
question by kevin rockwood he asked
what's the worst dish we ever made
i have notifications disrupting the
recording extremely unprofessional
i hope i will get invited back but it's
hard to say on this particular uh
fireside chat series
um but anyway yeah so
for me there's some dishes that were
one was just a mistake that was awful
the other was just a habitual issue i
have with cooking
um
so
first of all uh one time when i was like
dreamer bulking in college
i
wasn't paying attention
and
you know i was just like constantly
eating like
you've done a dream or bulk right where
you're just like i'm gonna eat as much
as i possibly can yeah that was like the
first 25 years of my life you just feel
sick you're not really paying attention
when you're putting the meals together
you're like oh here we are eating again
so i made some spaghetti noodles and
i was at that time shopping at costco
because like
i needed a million calories a day uh to
try to gain you know four pounds a day
this ridiculous bulk i was doing
so everything in my life was kirkland
brand right uh my ketchup my mustard my
socks my jeans everything in my life was
kirkland brand so i reach into the
refrigerator
kirkland brand red stuff got it
thought it was the spaghetti sauce it
was the salsa
but at this point i was too broke and
too committed to bulking to throw it out
and so i ate spaghetti with salsa
instead of uh spaghetti sauce and it was
absolutely disgusting i i don't know how
i managed to stomach it but it was
terrible i i think you're saving face
right now you you say you didn't do that
on purpose but i as a
as a proprietor of cincinnati chile i i
know that about you
i think you looked at the spaghetti
noodles and said i'm about to do
something here cincinnati tacos yeah you
can do anything just start with
spaghetti noodles and put
put whatever you want on it uh now
cincinnati style chili is fantastic it
really is um but but it's it's an
acquired taste it's always curious to me
though as someone who grew up there when
you see people absolutely revolted by it
and you're like this is just a normal
thing that that i grew up with like
it seems super normal
um now on to like actual terrible dishes
i've made to me it always seems to be an
issue of texture and
a big thing that that comes back to
haunt me frequently is just too much
moisture and i know why it's because i'm
very lazy right so all the steps you
would normally take to say you know what
i need to dry this out a little bit or i
need to crisp it up a little bit yeah
that's those are all extra steps that's
effort right so like for me if i'm
making some big like the one that comes
to mind is a quiche that i tried to make
and i'm thinking okay veggies eggs what
could go wrong but i'm so yeah i'm
really really lazy so i always get the
um
uh the frozen vegetables oh yeah that
are pre-fro you know pre-washed
pre-chopped they're sitting there in the
freezer when you need to use them you
get them out and honestly frozen
vegetables are fantastic they retain
their nutrients really well they're very
convenient very affordable and you don't
have to worry about spoilage because
like i'm sure everyone has been in that
situation where you're walking through
the grocery store and in your mind
you're the healthiest person you've ever
met right and you're like oh i'm gonna
tear through this fresh produce almost
instantly when i get home and then four
days later it's still in the
refrigerator like what am i gonna do
with 11 pounds of carrots yeah you know
so i like that it takes that pressure
off of you
just leave it in the freezer it's there
when you need it yeah you can you can
still never consume vegetables but
you're not creating food waste in the
process exactly yeah it's still
aspirational right i own vegetables yeah
whether or not i eat them it's it's an
investment basically
um but anyway so i'm like i'll make a
quiche i throw all this crap in there it
was absolutely disgusting like there's
just way too much moisture in all the
vegetables you're supposed to get them
fresh and crisp and chop them up
yourself
so for me that's like a constant issue
and uh i mentioned tim heidecker who
makes on cinema at the cinema uh last
episode he also made like a series of
five cooking shows on youtube that were
hilarious because uh he would always
mess up the the moisture level of the
dish and the whole series was basically
framed as him trying to make money from
a mustard sponsor
and so he would put a bunch of mustard
in and it'd be too thick and then he'd
just put water in the mustard bottle and
shake it up and try to like thin it out
a little bit and be too thin he would
just always go back and forth and that
just hit a little bit i like my comedy
to hit close to home but that was too
much that that made me uh it was just
too close for me but yeah with cooking i
i've had so many bad dishes that i just
packed it up and said
let's move on yeah that's that's fair
all right uh
corrine asks uh what is the worst thing
you've ever smelled do you want to do
you want to lead off on this one yeah
i'll go quickly here so we can get
through a bunch of of questions this
this is a great pivot from food topics
if yeah if anything up to this point was
at all appetizing to to the listener uh
just just get that out of your head
right well we went we went good food bad
food bad smell we're just kind of
shifting to a different sense here
um
it's funny i made my list and didn't
really think about it too too closely
and then i looked at it again today and
i said
this is just my life at the age of 17
which is really funny like
so the first things i wrote down that
came came to mind one was wrestling knee
pads and so a lot of lifters are going
to be able to identify with that because
it's like
a wrestling knee pad is like a lifters
um
knee sleeves
but just times a million right because
we're talking about like
sweating in them for like a full two and
a half hour practice where you would
usually lose you know because you would
actually track it you you'd often lose
four or five pounds of practice of sweat
right yeah it's not like i'll go hit a
triple wait for seven minutes like
wrestling knee pads just from the sheer
volume of use and the magnitude of sweat
and the wrestling itself is not the most
hygienic sport and that's an
understatement
wrestling knee pads are absolutely
disgusting
uh the second thing that came to mind
was a football locker room after a rainy
practice and i'm sure you've been there
uh all it takes is like two kids to not
bring their stuff home and leave it in
their locker and the entire locker room
is rancid
yeah so i um
i don't know how
general locker room hygiene worked at
your school but for for us the football
locker rooms would just smell
progressively worse throughout the
entire season yeah because we would take
our our practice jersey and practice
pants home and you know it was our
responsibility to watch them most most
of the the players were were pretty
responsible about that but it was on the
school to wash the shoulder pads
and you know like sweat
seeps into the shoulder pads like
there's there's a lot of foam padding
yeah
and um
they did that once a season yeah same
yeah so you would just have
mustier and mustier shoulder pads
you know with a pair hanging one in
every locker and we had we had like
between jv and varsity we probably had
130 kids playing football yeah so within
an enclosed pretty poorly ventilated
space
you've got
six month old ripening
uh shoulder pads yeah so yeah i mean the
the smell might vary a little bit day to
day but there was there was a clear
overall linear trend of just the locker
room getting more and more rancid as
this as the season progressed
yeah i i view it as you know it's like
watching you know
there's just those spikes you know
there's the upward trajectory but man
when you walk in just
after a rainy practice to me that's just
the worst and the third thing that came
to mind for me was a protein shaker
that's been left in a hot car that
that's to me about as bad as it gets for
smells and that's why you know i was a
meat head at the age of 12. so by the
time i was 17 my entire life was just
wrestling knee pads and football locker
rooms and protein shakers so
at the age of 17 at that point i had
already mostly lost my sense of smell um
just from like
allergies and deviated septums and the
whole deal
and it was for the best like the smell
is not something i need in my life now
here's the big question for you
how did you how did you combat all of
those bad smells that were
circling around you at 17 years old did
you shower all the time or were you an
axe body spray guy no no no i i sh i
showered okay yeah
there's a nice mechanism built in um
for
if you're a wrestler and you decide oh i
don't like to shower very often like
you're just going to get innumerable
skin diseases yeah uh so yeah with
wrestling it's like it
it's in everyone's best interest to just
shower regularly uh so so i i picked up
that habit from wrestling and yeah the
the axe body spray stuff you can get by
in like gym class
or like you know football maybe even
though that's a terrible idea but with
wrestling it's like you're
you're going to have harm done to you if
you don't shower
yeah
uh so for me
um
probably the worst thing i've ever
smelled is cat diarrhea
and you know
sorry sorry to just come out of the gate
with that yeah
but man like all cat excrement is just
absolutely disgusting um
and like
like cat cat poop itself is bad enough
but when they get a stomach bug
it's
it's uh
i i don't even want to think about it
i'm going to move on from that yeah
let's do that i like to when i think of
cats i think a little izzy and our our
noon time cuddle routine that we have
and that's my image of cats and we will
move forward yeah that's that's better
uh so
probably the second worst thing i've
ever smelled is uh
our our refrigerator died recently um
and so
there were like like you know things
that were previously refrigerated became
no longer refrigerated got up to room
temp
we had to throw a lot of stuff out uh
you know a lot of it hadn't actually
gone bad but it's like oh well this was
roomed him for like two like two days or
something yeah i don't i don't know if
this is completely safe to eat anymore
but there was one thing that was very
much not safe to eat and that was uh
some cheese sauce that i made like
three months prior it just got wedged in
the back of the fridge i completely
forgot about it yeah i mean it was very
rotten it was like growing mold oh god
and and the thing is like i've i've had
i've had that situation occur before
but
like
uh like temperature
temperature affects like gas dispersion
in general um so like colder things just
inherently don't have as strong of a
smell as hotter things because there's
like less kinetic energy in the gas
molecule so like fewer of them are are
coming up and hitting you in the nose
really hard
um but no like this this had
gotten to room temp and so
i was met with with the full force of
the of just this completely rotten
cheese sauce as i was cleaning out stuff
in the fridge
and uh yeah it was it was truly rancid
yeah um
like i so i'm i think i mentioned this
on the podcast before i know you know
this about me i'm very sensitive to bad
smells or just smells in general um like
if i'm in
an enclosed space like even like a car
with someone who's wearing way too much
perfume or cologne like
i will occasionally just black out like
or or even just an air freshener if
someone wait if someone has a new a new
air freshener in the car
i have to roll the window down and like
hang my nose out the window like a dog
so when you say black out you mean like
you'll lose consciousness or you'll be
you'll it's like a drinking blackout
where no no no what happened last night
like i i will lose i will experience
syncope wow um
so yeah like i is and and that also
applies to really bad smells like i
uh
like i i can't remember the last time i
threw up from being sick like it's it's
been a long time
but
i will
just like gag and sometimes just vomit
if i smell something that smells bad
enough
um
so i i'm actually taking this question
itself as a personal assault by corrine
uh attempt like making me relive uh some
some of the darkest moments of my life
and also uh forcing me to consider some
of what would have been the darkest
moments
in my life uh from your life so yeah
just uh you know i i expect more from
our listeners but this time corrine just
just let us down yeah so what's next
here uh dan mcgowan asks what are some
organizational habits that you employ to
improve
uh
that improve your work learning or life
so i like this because it represents the
duality of our show
we start out with a question about
cooking and i'm like forget all that you
don't need cooking cooking is irrelevant
get it out of your life
now the tables have turned when it comes
to organization and efficiency
that's my sweet spot uh greg has a
different approach but so for me
personally i'm going to talk a little
bit about uh organizing the space and
kind of the operations uh day-to-day so
first of all
i'm extremely averse to clutter and i
think a lot of people might be a little
bit surprised by that maybe i'm not sure
i'm not like i'm not really into
cleaning like i don't like scrub
everything so everything's like spotless
but i don't like stuff being all over my
desk i don't like things being out of
place i try to keep surfaces
largely open like i don't like stuff
sitting around everywhere so no clutter
for me is a really helpful strategy for
first of all not losing stuff but also
maintaining efficiency and keeping focus
when working
um
one habit that i try to employ
with work and learning
is the concept of deep work um i'm not i
don't look into the academic literature
in this area so this is all just kind of
you know when you listen to a podcast
about something and you're like i'm not
going to interrogate these ideas super
closely i'll take what's useful and
leave the rest right
but but i've heard some podcasts with
cal newport who's talked a lot about the
concept of deep work
and it's mostly focusing on the
potential downsides of failing to have
kind of a single-minded focus on a
particular object at a given moment
right so
uh an example would be you're at work
you're supposed to be writing an article
but you're checking in on an email
thread you know every few minutes
you have a slack channel that you're
kind of chatting with in an asynchronous
matter you've got people stopping by
your desk every every 20 minutes or so
to drop in it's really difficult to kind
of shift your focus away and dig back in
with a sufficient level of depth and
nuance you have to really kind of uh
immerse yourself into that material to
do that deep work and distractions
really oppose that so i take deep work
really seriously and to the extent that
it's responsible i try to block out
certain periods of time specifically for
writing
or statistical like any kind of number
crunching
where i turn off chat apps i leave my
phone in a different room no
notifications whatsoever sometimes i'll
even put a sign on on the door to my
office and just say
absolutely not yeah um so i think deep
work is really important and setting up
your work uh
you know your workflows so you have some
opportunities to have that deep work for
me at least that's important another
thing is i like to really invest a lot
of time and effort on the front end if
there's some task that i'm going to be
doing repeatedly especially if it's
going to be really central in terms of
importance
i really like to create efficient
systems on the front end rather than
patching things together as i go
i know some people like to just go with
the flow use their momentum and
enthusiasm and dive right in and say
we'll work out the the details later i'm
very different i like to start by saying
okay if we're going to do this at a
large scale and we're going to do it
efficiently and effectively what does
that actually look like in a way that is
sustainable and repeatable because
sustainable and repeatable prevents
burnout and prevents issues with quality
control you know if you're
um if the process isn't repeatable in an
efficient way
much greater likelihood that errors are
going to find their way in or just
fluctuations in quality in my opinion uh
and then along those lines uh i like to
really focus on
using i think it's really important with
any kind of when it comes to your work
habits and work processes
it's really important to think through
like what is the right way to to achieve
each particular function right so like
one of the biggest things in a workplace
that you have to think about is what
necessitates an in-person meeting what
should be done totally independently
with no distraction what should be done
in an asynchronous manner where you have
an email thread or like some kind of a
trello or slack type of of software
i think it's really important to figure
out what kinds of communications are
most suitable for what medium and
application
so i try to make sure that as much as
possible i am revisiting that as i go so
if i notice that i'm like okay we're
doing email [ __ ] that should not be
email this has no business be an email
this has to be done a different way i'm
very eager to readdress that as we're
going rather than say well it's how
we've always done it done it let's stick
with it you know so i do think it's
valuable uh not everyone has a
tremendous amount of autonomy in terms
of how they schedule their work and how
they organize their workday but if you
do have autonomy i think it can be
really helpful to be open-minded to
exploring different ways of doing things
um and i actually in the past have
leaned on others a lot if i'm about to
do something new
um so like for you know hypothetical if
you're about to get into podcasting it's
good to reach out to a few people who've
done it for a while and say like
if you were starting today
what what major mistakes would you have
avoided right so like if you go back and
start over help me see the stuff i'm not
seeing you know same thing when we were
really ramping up our coaching program
reached out to folks who have been doing
it for a while um so yeah i just think
it's to the extent that you have the
autonomy there it's really important to
to use that autonomy effectively and and
to lean on others for advice when you
can nice yeah uh so i i take a very
different approach um
i would say that i am chaos personified
uh and
that is i think it's just a
characteristic of who i am and quite
frankly it's how i like it um
when
when things are too organized and
structured i feel
uh extremely overwhelmed so like if uh
like
all day yesterday
i was i was dreading today uh and the
reason for that is there were
two
discrete time blocks on my schedule for
the day that had things scheduled so
you know
for 14 when not that much like 12 hours
of my day
i could
you know do do with my time what i
wanted uh but there were you know
like two hours here
there were like five hours of the day
were were pre-scheduled i was just like
jesus christ what am i gonna do like i'm
not gonna get anything done because
there are these two huge chunks of time
that like
what what the [ __ ] am i even gonna do um
like you you were mentioning uh deep
work yeah i
i
could not for my personal uh
circumstances i could not disagree with
that more strongly yeah so
um that that is how
my
teachers told me like oh that's how
you're supposed to do homework and
whatnot that's how my parents like made
me do homework and that is
how i attempted to work for probably the
first
six years that i was that i was doing
things and what i would find is that
and like this was even before um like
this was even before like social media
so you can't say like oh like you just
had your attention span ruined by social
media like i i
basically was never on the computer i i
had i did
there was nothing to distract me but i
just
could never focus on anything for very
long so you know i i would do like even
as like a kid like early in my career
whatever i would do like
10 to 20 minutes of like high quality
work and then just no matter what i was
doing trying to write something trying
to do like math problems uh
like
uh researching sources for like a term
paper i was writing whatever
like after like 10 to 20 minutes like i
just couldn't do it anymore like
whatever it was i would just stare at it
it went from like making sense and it
was something i could focus on to like
you know this is what my my visual
fixation is on and this is what i'm
trying to focus on but my my brain is
going
literally anywhere else um and so my
work process is i
attempt to
whatever i need to focus on i have it in
a standalone window so like i can i can
show this to the camera right now for
the youtube audience
like the the outline for this episode is
the only thing pulled up for me uh so
there's nothing to distract me now
but i always have distractions within
arm's reach so i have
everything else that i might want to do
to distract myself in another window
that i can access at any time and that
is tremendous for me so what i can do is
for
about 15 minutes i can really focus on
whatever i'm doing
get it get a surprising amount done in
that time period and then just go
distract myself with something for
like two or three minutes
and then come back to whatever it was
um
like that
i think the research and whatever else
all of the experts say that's not how
you should do it
but uh like i
i finally i think fully embraced that
about myself
about two years ago yeah and my
productivity has never been better like
that's that's been huge for me which i
guess is
is a kind of an organizational system uh
in a way but
yeah but i think that's important though
that you know
to draw on an analogy we you know we
always talk about these research studies
with a training program we say okay
overall you know if we look at this
meta-analysis with 360 different people
spread across you know x number of
studies we can say that for the average
person generally speaking approach a's
is a little bit better than approach b
right
but within that there's inter-individual
differences where some people it's the
complete opposite and they actually made
better progress with with the other
program right and so i i think it would
be silly to assume that every single
person has to approach work the same way
and says oh no i heard on a podcast that
actually the thing that's been working
for me for two years is not the best way
yeah you know it's important to try
different things but
if you have the empirical data that says
every time every time you try the thing
that's supposed to work it gets worse
then at a certain point you have to let
it go yeah you know yeah so so just just
in general i find that if my life if my
life has too much structure
i just
i just feel in a really deep level like
i'm being suffocated yeah uh so what i
do is
i do develop systems for
things that are very important uh and
things that like
absolutely can't slip through the cracks
that i would have
either either a reasonably high chance
of feeling overwhelmed because i would
feel like oh no there's so much i need
to do
um but like i don't and like i'm just
gonna have to keep going over and over
my to-do list in my head to make sure i
don't forget anything for things like
that you know
like most uh like the most standard
organizational tip possible just make
to-do lists like that's that's been
really helpful
for clearing more things out of my head
so that i can just more cleanly bounce
back and forth between work and
distractions without being like oh no
what's the next work task i need to do
uh then kind of for my next block of
focus
um
so to-do lists have been big uh meal
prepping has been really big um
like just
you know that that is one thing on my
week or like one thing on my schedule
every week like big block of time need
to get this done
um
but then it it alleviates the concern of
trying to figure out what i'm going to
eat uh for an entire week so like big
payoff there um
and then things that like i need to do
on like a weekly basis or a monthly
basis
uh just so i don't have to remember all
of that stuff i use uh boomerang for
gmail um like i i'm really bad about
checking my my google calendar and i
think the reason for that
is is like i mentioned before if i look
in my calendar and see like
three things on it i'm like oh no for
the week
well for for the week it's like four
things okay if there's three things in a
day though i'm just writing that day off
like it's already ruined so i don't want
to derail you too much but how did you
survive
doing
a study with human subjects
because like that is constant scheduling
and blocking off windows and things like
that right so as
as someone who lives in the chaos i'm
i'm just pretty good at doing that
um
like my my main organizational tool is
just my email inbox yeah and if there's
any
any to do tasks
associated with
an email like i'll i'll just mark it as
unread so you know i i know like just
from looking at my inbox like oh there
there are 25 emails marked as unread
including ones i've already responded to
like those are things that just uh at
the start of my work day just look back
and be like okay okay like here's what i
need to do
in each slot of time and i mean like i
did have to put that stuff on a calendar
like the lab calendars just for like
scheduling
space to do stuff uh but then i would
never look at the lab calendars i'd be
like no i i have to use my own system
because
brother looking at the lab calendars and
just seeing
just seeing every minute of every day
blocked off for the foreseeable future
in 11 different colors yeah it would
yeah i would just look at that and get a
cold sweat yeah uh like it took me a
week of grad school before realizing
like i could never do academia [ __ ] that
yeah uh
so yeah i i use uh i use boomerang to
give myself email reminders so so things
that i don't have to do at a particular
time but i do have to do on a
particular day
um like my main organizational system is
just like what is still sitting in my
gmail inbox and so
just having like automatic emails set up
and scheduled that send to me at 6am in
the morning saying like hey at some
point today you need to do this
that's smart i like that thank you uh so
yeah things that i have to do on a
particular day or or on a particular day
of the month that's that's my
organizational system for that
you know i i do something like that to
be honest uh you know it's funny because
i'll have the google calendar
that i could easily look at and should
but i will find the invite that i got
for that meeting and leave it unread
yeah until the meeting occurs because
every time i check my email it's like
remember you got that thing on thursday
so i i do some of that already uh but
yeah boomerang sounds good you should
give boomerang a shot because the the so
what you're describing is also what i
used to do but just kind of by by
necessity like things that are higher up
in your inbox are things that that you
kind of focus on more like if there's a
to-do task associated with an email
that's now like a month old like you've
looked at that email
every day for the past month and you
haven't had to do the thing associated
with it yet yeah and so at least i find
it's easier for that to just kind of
like become a part of the scenery and
you're not really looking at that
subject line anymore yeah um so by when
when something becomes scheduled i'll
just like schedule
uh an email and boomerang to send to
myself on the day that i actually have
to do the thing and then i can clear the
notification out of my inbox
and
and get it get a fresh one like when i
when i actually have to do it yeah it's
it's it's been pretty clutch
nice
all right uh i was thinking we might
skip ahead
we have a few things that are kind of
just like uh
efficiency work related i wonder if how
do you feel about skipping ahead to the
one about the loneliness epidemic yeah
let's do it getting into some bigger
topics here do you do you want to lead
off on this one
sure yeah so uh pleasant merit pawn i
can read yen okay yeah all right so so
from uh the subreddit pleasant merit
pawn uh says what are your thoughts
about the loneliness epidemic the
apparent phenomenon of people today
having fewer close friends and feeling
more lonely than in the past
uh what are potential causes impacts and
fixes
yeah so this is something that we've
talked about just like in social
settings when we're hanging out um and
so i know that
we kind of agree on on a kind of a major
causative factor there so i'm stealing
your thunder a little bit because you
put it in the out the outline first
but um you know one thing that seems to
be a trend in american culture like
that's the only culture i can
speak about with experience
but in american culture things have
generally become more secularized
over the last several decades um you
know there are fewer people who are
involved in church groups and who kind
of seek uh kind of a default community
of people within their you know whatever
religious group they happen to find
themselves in for a lot of people that
was where you find a sense of community
and if you need someone to you know
watch your kids or help you out around
the house whatever the case may be you
would go to to some type of
religious group or congregation and have
a community there and you know another
thing that that seems to be happening
more and more in recent decades is
there's a lot more mobility
and a lot of people move around from
city to city
you you don't find as many situations of
course they still exist but
you know you don't find a lot of
situations where three generations of
your family knows three generations of
multiple families on your street right
where all of your neighbors you know
their grandparents say hi to your kids
and everybody knows everybody as people
move around more you know i feel like a
lot of that becomes at least for me like
i don't have a close relationship with a
lot of my neighbors because i bounced
around a lot i mean in the last
decade i don't even know how many times
i moved from apartment to apartment and
eventually into a house um so it seems
that as people are moving around more
they're they're kind of
by default you have to kind of
re-establish a community and a network
every time you do that and you can stay
in touch with folks but it's not quite
the same uh and as people as as american
culture and society has kind of trended
more
secular in nature
we don't have those default kind of
religious congregations to lean on for
for some of those community purposes and
i was also um i was listening to a pod i
like the ezra klein podcast a lot and
they're talking a little bit about
the evolving workplace uh
intra and post covid
and how uh it kind of exposed the fact
that a lot of folks
were really leaning on the workplace to
provide them with meaningful
relationships a lot of people would kind
of because work in america has kind of
taken over larger and larger portions of
our day
especially with remote work where you're
kind of like
constantly tapping away all hours of the
day some people kind of graze on their
work rather than crunching it into a
discreet time window
work has just kind of taken over larger
portions of our day a lot of folks have
as they've gone away from kind of
religious congregations and institutions
they've and they're more mobile moving
every few years they've leaned more on
their workplace it seems to kind of
bring them meaningful relationships with
peers
and i think covid when a lot of office
buildings shut down and they said okay
you're on your own a lot of people
really noticed how much they were
leaning on their workplace to provide
social interaction that that was you
know not
you know specifically work related uh so
i think there's a lot of factors going
into what could be causing that that
increased sense of loneliness and a lot
of folks
and the question asked a little bit
about potential fixes and i don't know
if i have a lot of great advice here
because like you know i'm pretty
introverted and
my requirement for social interaction is
pretty low relative to most others
and it always makes you sound like an
[ __ ] when you say that because it's
like well i like me more than everyone
else so everybody everyone leave me
alone that's that's not the case it's
just like if you're really introverted
you enjoy having meaningful connections
and interactions with people but you
just kind of feel like it drains your
energy level like you have to really be
up and energetic and you just have a
finite amount of that where you say i
love interacting with everyone in this
room but my
my batteries drained i need to go
recharge a little bit
and so for me uh my requirement for
socializing is relatively low i like to
do it but you know in small amounts and
and i kind of have to recharge between
but one thing that has helped me because
even i need some you know social
interaction
i found that it can be really beneficial
to just go and do a thing that kind of
forces you to engage with people who
share some
overlapping interest you know so like
one of the first things i did in grad
school was i started coaching a special
olympics powerlifting team and i was
like listen i don't know how to make
friends i'm too awkward and introverted
for that
and who's got the time anyway but if i
show up to this thing i feel like
there's a good chance i'm going to
interact with someone that i really get
along with you know and i ended up
meeting a guy named dick landerman who i
coached with for like six years uh and
and i you know he's like a grandfather
to me you know he's a really fantastic
guy he's
hit the things he's done in his life are
absolutely incredible a really
phenomenal guy but like he's one of my
my the first people that when i moved to
to this area i was like hey i have a
friend in the community now he was like
probably four or five decades older than
me
but um but still i mean that's a
meaningful connection and almost like a
family type bond that we form there uh
and so like
i i think that getting into some kind of
hobby activity volunteer task religious
group
anything that kind of forces you into
those those
those opportunities for interaction i
think that can be a helpful thing
yeah i i agree with with virtually all
of that um yeah this is a conversation
we we've definitely had off mike before
um
so i don't have that much more to add
but i i do have a few
uh i i don't know a few a few thoughts
to maybe just like drill down into some
of these things a little more um
so you you mentioned that uh people just
move around a lot more than they used to
it's it's rare that like you your
parents your grandparents your
great-grandparents you know back five
generations all we're all born and lived
in like one small town
um
and i
i very much think that's true and i
think that it kind of reflects so i
think there's a bit of like a rural
urban split there yeah um like i i think
that
the
and this could run totally counter to
the data but this has been just kind of
like my general observation
where it seems like the the common
stereotype
is that like
rural families are the ones that are
like really tight-knit like the kids the
kids stay there like uh whatever and
but i i think i think more and more it's
actually becoming the opposite where
like
the
like i think people who have only ever
lived in cities or suburbs um
underestimate
the
the poverty and just like general
desolation of of not certainly not all
but like a lot of of rural america
um
and like yeah when so when uh when like
the opioid crisis kicked off uh and and
people were talking about deaths of
despair um i saw a lot of people being
like oh like this this is terrible like
how is this happening this is completely
out of the blue
and like as someone who who grew up in a
uh not particularly wealthy small town i
was like yeah yeah that checks out
a lot of the people who i grew up around
like if if they could get oxies on
demand to just kind of like
deal with their lives like yeah i think
they probably would have um
but so
like there there are dynamics in play
there so with with like rural
communities it used to just be like
family farms or like a relatively s uh
like like relatively small farms that
like people could work on for
generations or maybe just like one
family member would have a farm but like
all of the the kids and like cousins and
nephews and whatever would like go help
them out with it um
but like we're seeing uh
we're seeing like more and more
concentration of farming like fewer
small farms more just like huge
corporate farms that just don't need as
many people to work on them anymore um
it's like that kind of anchor for for
social stability in rural places is
is decreasing
um
and also like
a fair number of rural places there used
to just be kind of a
business that the community was built
around like a factory a mine whatever
and
like with especially factory jobs um
like post post nafta a lot of those jobs
have gone overseas
and so
you know people are like ah man like th
this community was just so much better
30 years ago and now like everything's
kind of dying like poverty is increasing
it's like well there's no capital
inflows to this community anymore like
there's
there's ultimately no big employer
like paying people and giving them money
to like go spend and like do other stuff
in the community so yeah like there
there are no jobs anymore so like of
course things are kind of getting
shittier
and so i i think that um
like a lot of the people i know who who
grew up in cities or suburbs where
they're
like they're they're certainly not every
city but like most cities kind of tend
to have more job openings and just more
opportunities and so you at least have
the option there to to do something and
also still be able to live with your
family some of the friends you grew up
with
uh
stay in in an area where you can be
around those people you have deeper
social bonds with
but for for a lot of people who grew up
in in rural places you're
you're basically forced to make the
choice of
like do i want to live in intense
poverty my entire life
or uh like leave my family looking for
opportunities yeah and like i i don't
think that decision comes easy for most
people um like i think they would often
like to be closer to family but it's
uh you know given
like given the post-nafta economic
conditions like it's it's just not
really like feasible
so um yeah i i think that uh
the
the loneliness epidemic like i think it
kind of affects everyone but at least at
least my perception is it
uh maybe hits rural americans a little
bit harder yeah um
another thing that i think uh probably
plays a role
is that uh
like there are just like more private
entertainment options than there used to
be so
you know there there's an infinite
amount of television like podcasts
youtube videos whatever and it's great i
mean you should be listening to
definitely this podcast and watching
these youtube videos for sure absolutely
um but like there there has been kind of
a a breakdown of monoculture and and
more things that you can do alone so
talking to like grandparents like great
aunts great uncles um like i i remember
as a kid just being like like what what
did you do when you were growing up and
uh
like things that were way more common
was like you know there's not a tv in
the house you want to do something like
you're going to play games as a family
or something or you're you're just going
to invite like
other families from the neighborhood
over and just like play board games
together cause you know you got five
hours in the evening to kill
what are you gonna do like you
is
it's either like you have to do
like there were books certainly but like
for the most part if you wanted to
entertain yourself
that tended to require other people or
it's just like ah man i got all day to
kill on a saturday what am i gonna do
um
let's just let's just walk down to the
town square just kind of sit on a bench
and uh you know
people i know are gonna walk by strike
strike up a conversation see where the
day goes um and
i i just don't think there's nearly as
much of that anymore because i i think
like in
the the immediate
uh
you know there there very well may be
like plenty of other things you would
rather do like there's probably
something on netflix that you would
rather watch
than you know go to the town square sit
on a bench and hope someone you know
walks by but yeah you know we're less
bored than we used to be and there there
are more just like private entertainment
options um which kind of pulls us into
ourselves uh
and
you know it gives less incentive to kind
of put yourself out there and try to
make friends
um so like maybe it's good for you in
the short term but like
maybe maybe not the best in the long
term and then i i mentioned like the
breakdown of the mono culture
um
so also talking like not so much to
grandparents but more like people from
from my parents generation who grew up
when there were
you know like four tv channels uh
like any show that was popular was like
like basically everyone watched it or
like 40 of people watched it or
something and so
you know like a big social thing in
america still is super bowl parties
because whether or not you care about
football like you probably know enough
people who do that you're you're gonna
get invited to a super bowl party like
that's that's pretty common um but you
know it used to be that that something
like mash was like that as well where
you might just have friends that you
just go watch mash with them every week
and like uh we do that in our friend
group so like game of thrones stuff
westworld which has just become an
absolute disaster but it's
it's our filth it's still fun to consume
with people um like that that's
something that that we can do that's
that's social and it's fun
um
but you know there's
i i i wouldn't want to guess what
percentage of americans watch westworld
it's definitely less than one percent um
and so you know that's that's one
with the breakdown of the mono culture
there's
uh fewer things that you know will be
firm conversation topics with strangers
uh like if you were to meet a new a new
person because
like
there used to be a higher probability
that if you struck up a conversation
with someone you could be very confident
you'd have at least one shared interest
or like shared cultural touchstone and
that's
much less common now
uh and also like you know there there
were just more things that just kind of
like more entertainment options that
kind of gave you an excuse to have
friends over watch it together have have
a little uh like a a little bit of a get
together um so yeah like i think all of
those things contribute
and in terms of potential fixes like i i
agree with with everything you said um i
think
i think the big thing is it it used to
just be more the case that
um like you you still had to put
yourself out there to like meet people
and make friends but
you were
more nudged into situations where that
would be easier um and it would
kind of more happen just by general
osmosis uh where now
it does it does take more pers like it
takes more purposeful effort to
intentionally try to meet people and
become friends with them
um
like like i
like speaking for myself i've got a
pretty decent friend group now
but like i i was i was lonely as hell
like my first
probably five years out of college for a
lot of these reasons moving around all
the time um didn't really get plugged
into
social things when we moved places
because like yeah we'll probably be gone
in six months anyway kind of what's the
point
um
and like yeah uh it it sucked and so
like one of the reasons we we wanted to
settle down um
so like when we moved to raleigh
uh
and then like a year or two later i was
looking at grad school one of the things
that sold me on unc was just like it's
pretty close to raleigh so we can keep
hanging out with some of the same people
keep doing some of the things that we
were previously doing like going to
trivia every week and like hanging out
with our trivia team um
and then you know certainly just like
moving back to raleigh after after grad
school just just because like
by that point i had put in a fair bit of
effort into starting to build a friend
group yeah and it's just like yeah i
know how [ __ ] bad i felt before i had
that and if if we go somewhere else for
grad school or move somewhere else after
grad school other than raleigh and back
to our friends like it's gonna suck
again and it's gonna be another like
three four year process of of trying to
build a new social circle um
but yeah like it it didn't happen by
osmosis like it took
a pretty reasonable amount of like
purposeful effort to do it um and i i
think that just used to not be the case
quite so much yeah
so
we've got an another one here that i
think is really relevant because it ties
in pretty well with an article that you
recently wrote um
so we've got a question here from
nom bringer mm-hmm
basically wanting to know what is some
stuff to do
that isn't training
for people who are absolutely addicted
to training so the back story here is it
sounds like this individual had a pretty
serious injury
luckily they expect a full recovery
but
um you know they mentioned that
being unable to train for a while it
kind of feels like there's a big part of
their life missing which is really
relatable you know we we get uh so into
training and it becomes such a big part
of our life and then when we're forced
to kind of take some time away it can be
really really difficult um and so the
individual goes on to say i like to dive
into things and take them pretty
seriously
but anything that i pick up now it's got
to be pretty temporary in nature because
eventually i'll be back into my training
pretty hard and won't have time for this
so
it brings up an interesting question of
what do you do you know some people even
struggle on just days off of training
right where it's like oh my god i have
to take two days out of the gym every
week how am i gonna fill those two days
right and then for some people it's
longer things where they're like okay i
can't really train for eight weeks what
can i do to kind of fill that gap and
this this um i mentioned the relevance
here because you recently wrote an
article for mass
which was cross published on stronger by
science.com and it was all about
the more
focused stuff of when you when you take
a layoff or take some time out of the
gym
how quickly does detraining occur how
severe is it how quickly can you build
back up so it focused more on the in the
gym aspects of d training and returning
to training but this is focusing more on
the stuff outside of the gym uh just
kind of filling that void so so do you
have any advice for them
yeah so i i've got a
a kind of fun recommendation and a
super practical recommendation uh and
i i think i think
both
i i think one or the other will will
appeal to this individual um
depending on what they most enjoyed
about training so they
they mentioned in the question
um
that
they they have to be immobilized so
you know one consideration is hey if the
thing you like about training is just
kind of like moving around getting your
heart rate up getting a sweat on feeling
like you're you're bettering yourself
physically um you know if if you have
like an upper body injury you can still
like go for a walk do do lower body
exercise whatever but if you're like
fully immobilized
uh like based on the way this question's
worded i assume that that's off the
table
so one of the other things that people
get from training that kind of like
meets meets a psychological need for
them
is just kind of the
uh the feeling of accomplishment of of
mastery and feeling like you're you're
progressing at something uh picking up
new skills improving at something that
matters to you
and so um
if if those are the sorts of of itches
that training scratches for you
you could just look around for new
skills to acquire that might be useful
for you um
that you can you can do in bed while
immobilized so uh for example you could
attempt to like you know
over the span of
rehab like you're never going to become
like fluent in a new language but you
know if you maybe have an idea like i'd
kind of like to do some international
travel in a couple years or something
and you you might have a destination in
mind
you could just like really intensively
try to get you know probably not even
conversational but like learn learn
enough of the language that you'll be
able to communicate with people get
around better um and you know so you'll
you'll
you should be able to tangibly improve
at those language skills pretty quickly
that that might feel good to you um or
it could be something like picking up uh
some sort of skill like something you
can do with your hands that
you maybe don't have to do all the time
but is is sort of the type of skill
where it's like riding a bike like you
pick it up and you never really forget
it so you know you can maybe learn how
to like knit or sew which
uh
seems ridiculous but i i learned how to
sew when i had like a an mcl injury when
i was younger and i'm not going to
pretend like i sew all the time but i'd
say once every other year or so um a
situation comes up where it's where it's
useful to have that skill uh and i'm
glad i learned it um
or
if if it's not so much that you'd like
to to pick up and learn a useful skill
um but you do you are still very uh
motivated by kind of the pursuit of
mastery something you could do is just
try to pick up and learn
a hard video game where
like progression will be very obvious so
i know for for a lot of gamers like i've
never played any of like
the from soft games like the dark souls
games uh
uh sakuro
elden ring stuff like that i have no
idea what's happening here i i've never
it's totally fine yeah uh but they're
they're notoriously difficult video
games okay and
the
the way that i hear gamers talk about
them and the
sense of accomplishment they get when
they beat a boss that had previously
beat them like 50 times like that so the
the thing people like about those games
is they're they're very hard but as i
understand it for the most part they're
fair like you might just get killed in
just kind of traversing between areas
because an enemy falls out of the sky
and stabs you in the back like that
that's kind of a [ __ ] death yeah but
in terms of the boss fights which people
say are the hardest parts of the game
apparently the boss fights are very fair
like the bosses have a fixed number of
attacks they do and it's
it's the sort of thing where
if if you are good enough at the game
they they won't just kill you with
[ __ ] like it's always beatable and
it's just a matter of player skill um
and yeah so when i hear people talk
about those games it sounds
the sorts of words they use in emotional
language they use sounds a lot like the
sense of accomplishment lifters describe
when they hit pr's yeah um so you know
for
just like scratching an itch kind of in
the short term
just just picking up a hard video game
and trying to get good uh might be
uh pretty motivating you know i know a
lot of people like to take a dig at like
the the emergence of esports and kind of
really competitive video gaming um
just because it's kind of a newer thing
and i think uh people stigmatized video
games back in the days being like well
if you're playing video games you're
wasting your time right you're not doing
something productive for society but
like when you think about it you know
you mentioned when they talk about
uh
you know experiencing that that personal
best it does sound reminiscent of other
elements of achievement and more
traditional um you know sports or
endeavors
and it's basically the same right like
you being a good power lifter is no
better for society than someone doing
better at a video game than they used to
and at the end of the day it's all like
okay we're gonna agree on a set of
constraints we're gonna agree what
achievement
is
everybody have at it you know and within
that context like it's very
understandable why someone would feel a
similar sense of accomplishment yeah
um yeah so
i i really focused on the fact that this
um this listener mentioned they like to
dive into things and take them pretty
seriously uh and i definitely relate to
that i will admit it's something that
i'm trying to get away from a little bit
i think i i do have a
a habit that is just kind of built into
my code where i'm i'm really focused on
achievement and competition and things
like that i think it'd be better if i
could be a little bit less focused on
goal striving and a little bit more
focused on just kind of enjoying the
process of things rather than the
outcome exclusively but nonetheless um
i think something that that really draws
me to certain endeavors that busy my
mind are things that i can compete in
um just because it's kind of a constant
sense of feedback and you it's it's
easier to get that sense of mastery when
there's objective empirical data and you
say well i used to do this well but now
i do that well right and you can watch
that progress and say well i used to
place around sixth or seventh at these
competitions now i'm top three right you
can watch that progress uh so something
that enables competition and you know
even if you're not um you know like you
said if it's a really rough injury and
you're totally immobilized i mean video
games getting into like chess and other
types of interactive online games where
you can compete against others and and
try to really enhance your skill set you
know that that would be one way to do it
also just things that yield an
observable outcome right so making a
piece of art building a useful thing
doing a big project around the house
that you've been meaning to do for years
i think those things can be really uh
really fulfilling you know so like you
know maybe there is
some set of circumstances where i might
say you know what i'm gonna get into
cooking and become a very good chef
uh i think you would like it if you if
you got into it
i think if
if i could somehow do it without needing
to wash so many dishes i really think
that that is you've got a girlfriend
i know but i mean i'm i'm the one with
professional dishwashing experience yeah
i'm a professional also that was a joke
by the way yeah you that was a joke
you've been canceled no uh
usually uh that is the biggest
constraint for me with cooking is like
you may have noticed greg
almost every meal i've ever made is a
one-pot dish yeah
that's not a that's not a mistake it's
not a coincidence
i hate doing the dishes uh probably
because i have
i mentioned in the last episode working
in in uh the uh the food industry
very very difficult work i still can
vividly remember just being in the back
of a restaurant washing the dishes
uh the restaurant i worked at every
single dish was like
gravy and cheese and just the stickiest
stuff that if you left it out for 10
minutes it would stick to the plate like
concrete yeah you know like super glue
so i'm back there with the steel wool
just cranking away boiling water you
know my hands are uncomfortably hot and
just trying to get the crap off these
dishes
the servers are coming back where's all
the plates we're out of plates and i'm
like there's nothing i can do wait so
you you had to basically like hand wash
everything
effectively i mean there there were so
many dishes on the menu that had those
types of things that would just stick to
the place that you kind of just go in
the dishwasher oh that's the automated
yeah the automatic dishwasher you pull
it down and yeah you know
it was great but it wasn't that great
yeah yeah i couldn't do that
so i mean yeah i just dude those those
like industrial dishwashers though are
so sick you should get one it's
essentially an autoclave and it it
washes your dishes in like five minutes
you should get one
i might i think it would be cool i
honestly might yeah um but no so
yeah i i like i said
getting into something where you're
producing something tangible like i
think it'd be really cool to get better
at building stuff
my girlfriend's mother is so good at
building stuff like really excellent
woodworking and carpentry skills like
you've seen her backyard like everything
in her backyard she built right like
there's like a dock back there and
chairs and like just everything um so
yeah seeing those types of things seeing
someone who's good at cooking make a
great dish seeing someone who's great at
carpentry builds something that's that's
really well done uh you you can see how
that would give you that same sense of
fulfillment and getting back to the
question it is the type of thing that
you can put on the back burner and pick
it back up later you know so you can get
back into training and love it um but
you could still you know say you know
what maybe on the weekends i am going to
continue doing some of the carpentry
stuff some of the woodworking so yeah i
would just uh if i were in that
situation and uh i have been before i
try to just focus on
you know some of my biggest uh
writing projects i've been i've
decided to dive into them
when i'm unable to train because you're
just like whatever let's make something
here you know
so yeah i would focus on that stuff and
uh i think that answers the question um
do you want to do one more and and wrap
it up up to you yeah is there a good one
left here i think so uh a good
a question that invites us to look back
on our lives which i think will put a
nice a nice final bow on this episode
so uh good morning squat from reddit uh
asks do you feel you've accomplished all
the major life goals you set out for
yourself as a kid
um yeah so as a kid i wanted to be a pro
baseball player uh and i i also wanted
to be a weatherman i want to be a
meteorologist specifically
on a local news channel um you know the
weather channel didn't exist back then
so when you were when you were the
weather person like
at local news stations there's kind of a
hierarchy of who really calls the shots
yeah and
the sports person is pretty high up
there but the weather person is like top
priority right so the sports person can
be given an update on the teams the
weather the weather person says no cut
them out i'm going live i've got a
tornado in the background right
so um no i just i was really interested
in meteorology when i was a kid
um obviously i fell short of that goal
uh if anything i've i've lost
i i know less about weather than i did
when i was like 11.
so i went completely the wrong way with
that uh and then pro baseball player uh
i ditched that when i was like 15. i was
like
in a position where i was like i'm
either gonna focus on these like hyper
athletic like wrestling football sports
or the skill development associated with
high level baseball i mean that's not to
take away from the athleticism of
baseball players there are exceptional
athletes playing baseball but there's so
much technical skill required in that
sport you do kind of reach a point
maybe i reached a point because i have a
limited skill set but you you also just
don't have good enough vision
that's true like the the the typical
20
if you have 20 20 vision
you can't hit a curveball
effectively like that's
uh like
pro baseball players have
i forget if it's 10 20 or 2010 but it's
you know they're they they tend to be
like in in the upper like
like 98th percentile or above for visual
acuity because like you you need it to
pick up on on spin of breaking pitches
soon enough out of the pitcher's hand
yeah i used to be very good at hitting
curve balls but they were also not
exceptional curveballs yeah you know i
mean i i think it's not going to drop 18
inches off the table and still be coming
at you at like 82 miles an hour yeah and
at that level when you're still 15 or 16
you can
the pitchers are not delivering the
pitches in a way that's highly
repeatable you know you can just see
from the way that the elbow and the
wrist are are oriented you're like okay
i got a i got a curveball coming yeah
like the the fingers are right behind
for the four seamer and and you you just
like see the whole ball in their hands
because they're throwing their curveball
like like a football basically yeah and
and before they start their wind up
they're just working in the glove trying
to get that curveball grip yeah it's uh
it's it's a bit different for sure but
for me the biggest thing was like i felt
like when i was doing my wrestling stuff
and trying to build up strength and
power it was really substantially
benefiting football and vice versa
and then baseball when i was working on
those skills i was like i don't think
this is helping me out much in the other
two and i just kind of reached that fork
in the road and chose you know and again
this is just a personal limitation
because they're people that are actually
good athletes dude they just do like a
sport every season until they're like 26
and they're like yeah i'm just great
i went to high school with a kid who was
he he played division one football
basketball and baseball right dude is a
freak athlete that wasn't me i needed to
differentiate and so my my pro baseball
player dreams were
uh crushed so
personally
to to give a a piece of unsolicited
advice
obviously it's it's very clear when you
talk about childhood goals but i do
think it's important for people to like
goal setting is good goal striving is
good goal attainment is good
uh
goals can serve a very valuable purpose
in our lives but it's also important to
give yourself an opportunity to adjust
your goals as you go like
there are some people who set a goal
that's relatively arbitrary and they're
like well no going back now because if i
don't do this i'm a quitter and there
you might reach a point in your life
where like this goal no longer serves
the purpose that it did when it was set
and it might be better for me to
adjust my goal so obviously it's
difficult to say when it's time to cut
bait on a goal but i do think it's
important to at least like have a pair
of scissors right like at least keep
your eyes open and say is this goal
actually still a productive and valuable
thing in my life yeah
so so for me as a kid i wanted to be a
fire truck yeah um
and i i feel like i've made just about
as much progress towards that goal as as
i could reasonably expect um
i i think i'm certainly redder than the
typical person
um
i'm relatively large
uh
as far as humans go i think i have
relatively high horsepower
and uh i know how to use a hose so like
you know it is i've done just about
everything i can um and then until
until really extreme body modifications
hit the market uh
i i would say i haven't accomplished
that goal that i set for myself as a kid
but i've
uh i've doggedly pursued it every day up
to this point and i i'm pretty proud of
how far i've come
you know there's one thing that
you might be closer than you think so
now you've gotten into the audio medium
oh i can get a hover round oh well no we
do podcasting now which is a progression
that's something you didn't used to do
so now you you
you are on air voice talent and so you
could if they continue to crank out
these cars movies the cars franchise
i mean you could be a fire truck in like
cars 13.
that that would be sick yeah so it might
be doable
i still think fire trucks are very cool
yeah uh anyway so no i i didn't meet
that goal that's fine yeah all right so
let's let's wrap it up um as always if
you enjoy the podcast make sure to
like rate subscribe if you're listening
to this on youtube drop a comment down
there for the algorithm um
if you want to keep up to date with the
uh with the content we put out uh
including the research briefs we publish
every wednesday make sure to sign up to
our newsletter the link to do that will
be in the show notes
if you
uh if you yourself maybe
you set a goal as a kid that
i you know i'm i'm five years old uh and
i would really like to squat 500 pounds
at some point in my life and now you're
in your 20s or 30s and you're still like
yeah 350 400 something like that and you
think
i think some coaching could help me get
there and so if a time machine's ever
invented i could go back and tell my
five-year-old self yes like you will
squat 500 in the future if you think you
might need help to get there we do have
coaching and you can find the link to
stronger by science coaching in the show
notes as well
um
let's see if you want high quality
supplements that are already cheap and
you want to get them for five percent
cheaper yet go to bulksupplements.com
use the code sbspod at checkout
if you want even more
in-depth scientific
content related to building muscle
getting stronger improving body comp etc
you should check out the mass reach
research review eric and i are half of
that along with eric helms and mike
zordos uh
really high quality stuff check that out
and uh finally if you have nutrition
related goals um you're maybe you're
currently a a refugee from myfitnesspal
after they announce their their
paywalling barcode scanning uh or you
know you you would just like to uh see
what's out there and see uh and just
check out nutrition tracking apps uh
take a peek at macro factor uh that is
that is the app that uh we helped design
along with our incredibly talented
developers cory and rebecca uh there's a
two-week free trial if if you'd like to
take a peek and a a link to macro factor
will be in the show notes as well or you
can just search it on the app store and
play store
uh i think that about does it for this
fireside chat hope you enjoyed it and as
i mentioned earlier in the episode uh
normal
um you know the standard
uh fitness and nutrition science content
will be back next week and we'll see you
then
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top if you want
to join in on the stronger by science
podcast conversation be sure to check
out our facebook group and our subreddit
the links for both are provided in the
description of today's episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you